it's the most significant prisoner swap
since the War Began
215 Ukrainian soldiers released by
Russia in a deal brokered by turkey this
is definitely a victory for our state
for our entire Society but most
importantly the 215 families will be
able to see their loved ones in safety
Mr President dear fellow ukrainians I am
eternally grateful to you for bringing
us back thank you very much emotions are
overwhelming in a separate deal
facilitated by Saudi Arabia 10
foreigners fighting alongside Ukrainian
forces have also been released
most of the Ukrainian soldiers released
were part of the so-called azov regiment
that held out for weeks defending the as
of Stahl steel plant in mariupo despite
being surrounded and shelled by Russian
forces they finally surrendered in May
as part of the agreement five of the
unit's commanders will remain in Turkey
until the end of the war the soldiers
that fought at as of stall are
considered national heroes here in
Ukraine you can see signs of it all over
Kiev and while many were released in
this prisoner swap it's believed
hundreds more are still being held as
prisoners of War other Russians to hold
up its end of the bargain Ukraine has
freed 55 Russian soldiers as well as
Victor medveduke a Ukrainian oligarch
and former lawmaker who was jailed on
treason charges in the early days of the
war Vladimir Putin is Godfather to
Medford juke's daughter
in Russia some bloggers have criticized
the Kremlin saying it gave up too much
but for ukrainians there's happiness but
tempered only by fears for those still
detained
finally they're all free but I think all
of Ukraine is worrying for all of those
of those family it's a huge tragedy to
lose a loved one but for those who are
returning it's happiness
while the prisoner swap is a positive
sign of diplomacy it's not expected to
last with neither side willing to
compromise the fighting rages on Gabriel
ozando Al Jazeera Kiev